[Musique]
on va gagner cette bataille comté par
comté région par région
tous enfants les québécoises et les
québécois feu exigent du changement
cette année à la can on est là pour
faire plus pour faire mieux pour tous
les québécois
on ne fait pas ce qu'on passe de ce
combat c'est ce qu'elle québec mérite
ce logo bonjour bonjour monsieur vois
pas ce que peu comme un sportif vous
êtes en avance plus vous jouez fessiers
là vous avez vous avez hâte ça finisse
là c'est sûr que j'aimerais ça que les
actionnaires demain matin le débat
demain matin mais en même temps c'est
agréable
soto n'était connu des campagnes
électorales du ve on était d'aller dans
les festivals rencontrer des gens qui
sont de bonne humeur
donc c'est agréable est-ce que vous
allez être aussi disponibles que les
autres campagnes électorales pour les
journalistes parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on vous a protégé un peu depuis six
mois ce projet subventions on vous
envoie t mais c'était voulu un ce que
j'ai voulu faire depuis six mois depuis
le début de l'année 2018 c'est de
montrer mon équipe donc des jours où
j'ai sorti ce nom je les barrettes jean
françois roberge françois parent est que
les gens un commentaire négatif qu'on
savait qu'on ne reçoit plus aujourd'hui
donc ça fonctionnait cette stratégie de
montrer les crocs mais en campagne vous
allez tous est disponible que les autres
campagnes cap fall en ontario fin de
campagne oui c'est une stratégie la
mesure a refusé d'être moins disponibles
être vous tenter par ce nom je suis sur
le terrain tous les jours c'est vrai
depuis le début de l'année ça va être
vrai pour être au moins un demi qui
viennent j'ai pas prévu prendre de
vacances je venais dans les différentes
régions du québec
puis je rencontre souvent des
journalistes qui sont plus des
journalistes locaux
c'est très bien et puis je présente nos
candidats aux candidats donc si ce que
je ferai à travers le québec
mais je vais pas me cacher le pendant
une semaine de temps à tous les jours
j'ai quelque chose votre état d'esprit
vous un peu comme un boxeur qui rentre
dans un rêve et état d'esprit comment
vous préparez ce qu'on veut c'est des
prep toute l'équipe soit prêt donc on a
125 candidats candidat est bon il ya des
préparations qui se font le cadre
financier
les propositions chiffrées à chacune des
journées de la campagne donc toutes ces
équipes lot la publicité je m'en occupe
quand même là je dis rend compte et puis
je m'assure que tout le monde soit prêt
que tout le monde prenne un levier pour
acquis parce que c'est vrai on est
premier des sondages donc ça serait
facile de s'asseoir puis comme vous êtes
jouer fessiers ce parce que je veux
faire
1 je veux qu'on se bat à chaque jour
pour faire le mieux possible et le moins
d'histoire le bouillonnec possible c'est
sûr que des histoires lui un candidat
que poser un geste qui était pas
souhaitable on en souhaite pas beaucoup
de tours
donc effectivement on tient à vous de
bien réagir à tous que la première
journée vous n'êtes pas sorti
on vous leur reprochez vous le maintenez
comme président action candidats je
pense que personne qui veut le crucifix
pl mais qui sont encore président du
parti si tu vas trop comprendre ce que
ça veut dire un président politique en
politique le chef ses chefs le président
on garde au parti québécois c'est qui au
parti libéral c'est qui on les connaît
parti libéral on connaît un peu plus
parce que tu es très connu ok mais vous
mais vous êtes vous êtes pas dit dans le
fond je devrais l'enlever la présidente
on s'est posé la question mais sauf que
bon ce que je lui demande est ce qu ont
décidé c'est de se retirer du conseil
d'adminstration vendre ses actions liste
associés qu'une entreprise qui avait
certaines activités dans les autres
provinces
tout pousse la table qui représente la
polyvalence pour jacques vous avez voir
exactement donc moi je les ai dites
générales et puis bon mais ça mérite pas
d'aller le crucifié puiser non mais mais
qui ne soit plus président a peut-être a
montré que vous c'est toléré parce qu'on
a mis son travail actuellement c'est
vraiment d'être quand je pense pas
qu'ils feront rien comme présidente
partie bonne écoute
actuellement les gens on est en campagne
en inde directrice de campagne de lutte
le go ce que tout soit en place donc ce
nature qu'on travaille le temps ouais
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez comme temps
parce que je veux pas non plus il
réalise santé bien sûr lors des attaques
il faudra les attaques entre les parties
mais on s'aperçoit que sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple le ton est
épouvantable ça vous atteint qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez mais moi ce que je
souhaite c'est une campagne positive sur
les trois grandes priorités que les
priorités que moi je vois je pense la
population voit stade et l'éducation
l'économie la santé
donc on parle de nos propositions c'est
sûr que si tu me fais attaquer
je peux pas avoir la du gore victimes
faibles qui répliquent pas nos médias
les libère ou les voleurs armés de
bâtons a géré les gens avez vous
l'impression qu'ils en ont assez des
exagérations
les gens sont tannés de cette chicane le
convoi période des questions ou personne
n'écoute personne
des gens ce qu'ils veulent savoir ce
qu'est ce qu'on a à leur offrir
justement après la pause on va parler de
votre programme sur le guen deux minutes
et demie à tout
si le fédéral impose un pipeline par
exemple mais ils ont fait la colombie
britannique
parce que vous revient de rire
souverainiste
[Musique]
le changement c'est d'abord ça offrait
un gouvernement qui est proche des
préoccupations des québécois françois
legault biais d'ententes devant vos
militants vous dites les québécois
veulent du changement
vous avez quand même un défi là dessus
vous avez été élu il ya 20 ans donc
entre guillemets un vieux politiciens
qui vint du changement aussi
d'abord j'ai jamais été premier ministre
on sait que les premiers ministres ont
beaucoup de pouvoir dans le choix des
priorités
donc évidemment si j'ai la chance d'être
premier ministre va pouvoir choisir les
priorités ce que j'ai jamais pu faire
depuis 18 ou 20 ans donc c'est différent
par les priorités puis peut-être qu'on
se croise les doigts le peut-être cette
fois-ci on va vraiment parler
d'éducation dans une campagne électorale
parce que souvent on dit on va en parler
on n'en parle pas beaucoup
l'éducation votre mesure phare vous
c'est la maternelle 4 1 pour tout le
monde c'est réaliste et assez d'argent
pour ça oui oui ce qu'on a besoin c'est
de dépister le 20 % d'enfants qui ont
les discuter d'apprendre ça dysphasie
dyslexie troubles d'attention autisme
pendant le docteur carreman qui est
maintenant parmi nos candidats qui est
un médecin neurologue de sainte justine
qui est spécialiste pour dépister est le
premier problème qu'on a c'est qu'on
dépiste à cinq ans alors qu'on devrait
dépistés à trois ou quatre ans puis une
fois qu'on a des pistes et les enfants
qui ont des difficultés faut commencer à
leur donner des services dès l'âge de 4
ans c'est plus efficace dans une école
avec des enseignants des orthophonistes
orthopédagogue que dans une garderie
mais effectivement il va y avoir un
débat pq parti libéral veut le protéger
les garderies je comprends ça mais en
même temps surtout pour le 20 %
d'enfants qui ont des difficultés
ça prend la maternelle 4 as a fait ses
preuves ailleurs oui puis à des
spécialistes qui recommandent depuis
longtemps en ontario mais à quel prix
pas combien de temps ça va oui mais ça
va être dans notre cadre financier mais
c'est réaliste c'est pas si coûteux que
pouvoir sur dix est réaliste annoncé 111
elle classe de 4 ans puis 10 il peut pas
faire d'autres pensent que oui ok puis
bon ça coûte peut-être 1 3 400 millions
mais on a donné un milliard de trop aux
médecins spécialistes quand on compare
avec l'ontario puis on se donne un
mandat de quatre ans pour mettre en
place des maternelles oui à certains
endroits va falloir agrandir des écoles
dans certain qu'on va c'est peut-être de
demander à des techniciens de câbles de
compléter leur formation pour devenir
enseignant mais nous on pense qu'en
quatre ans on est capable d'offrir à
tous les enfants tous les enfants tous
les enfants actuellement il ya seulement
5 % savez ça fait longtemps qu'on parle
de ceux d'une dizaine d'années il ya
seulement 5 % des enfants qui ont accès
mais est-ce que ça va être au détriment
du réseau des cpe
bah écoutez d'abord ça se reproduit à 3
mais c'est ce que dit non mais soyez oui
mais je suis chute la main puis on veut
dire la vérité il ya des clients un des
enfants qui actuellement sont des dates
dans des garderies qui vont peut-être
préféré leurs parents vont préférer les
envoyer à la maternelle 4 1 qui sera
gratuit donc effectivement ça peut être
difficile pour certaines garderies mais
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on dit
qu'il manque de places dans les
garderies que ça devrait au moins réglé
le problème de places dans les garderies
puis pensons à stion mieux pour les
enfants
si ça vous apercevez que ça se fait mais
il faut que financièrement vous preniez
les bouchées doubles est ce que vous
pourriez vous seriez ouvert a même fait
un léger déficit pour ce pays ce genre
de priorité écoutez
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer des
milliards je te dis je répète un
milliard de trop médecins spécialistes
ont dépensé 800 millions de trop en
technologies de l'information
ça coûte 3 400 millions dont vous dire
on n'a pas le luxe de ne pas investir
dans les enfants de 4 ans parce qu'on a
un problème de diplomation au québec ont
absolument 76% diplomation en ontario
c'est 86%
il ya des pays comme la finlande qui
vont jusqu'à 95 pour ça donc on peut
faire mieux ont le devoir de donner ce
qu'ils annulent ces enfants là mais je
repose la question donc pour vous c'est
clair que même en investissant
massivement dans l'éducation
il y au delà il ya des moyens une marge
de manoeuvre siala pour pas faire de
diffuser tire pas difficile et on écoute
et puis on a dans notre équipe des gars
comme françois bonnardel erika qui
m'arrache la tête on allait chercher de
trésorier de la banque nationale et eric
girard là c'est un gars rigoureux et
eric girard permettra jamais qui est
difficile je trouve pas mais justement
là-dessus la parenthèse vous rapprocher
beaucoup gouvernement libéral d'avoir
sabrer dans les écoles puis vous dites
je lui pardonnerai jamais d'avoir coupé
pour les élèves en difficulté etc
or vous avez aussi comme engagement de
faire des visites 0 vous auriez pas
trouvé de coffre au trésor n'ont plus
regardé est à peu près cinq cent
cinquante mille employés ou qu'ils
avaient et en a 350 milles qui donne des
services puis 200 milles qui sont en
appui dans les bureaux c'est du côté de
la bureaucratie qu'il faut couper vous
continuez à dire que cela il ya encore
d'autres guillemets du gras allait
couper ce pas un médecin qu'on répète
c'est certain mais en plus une
opportunité dans les prochaines années
le les baby boomers vont prendre leur
retraite donc il va y avoir à chaque
année vingt mille personnes qui vont
prendre leur retraite sur une base
volontaire
donc il s'agit qu'une partie de ces
personnes là qui sont dans la
bureaucratie que leur posture pour
remplacer pour qu'on fasse beaucoup
d'économies des économies qui devraient
être investis entre autres en éducation
donc malgré les années d'austérité vous
étiez encore du gras dans la fonction
publique
dans la bureaucratie trois endroits
d'abord technologies de l'information on
parle de 800 millions cédé contre eux
c'est un peu un bar ouvert qui donnait
des compagnies privées donc 800 millions
d'économies
je reviens aux médecins spécialistes
parce que les gens réalisent pas de
combien on parle
actuel meilleur c'est vous qui avez
parti balle et quels médecins
spécialisés j'avais dit qu'on était en
2002 j'avais le dis vous faire un
rattrapage vers un rattrapage mais on
avait un rattrapage à faire à peu près
de 40% que l'ontario eut en fait un
rattrapage d'à peu près 60% vous
aujourd'hui les médecins spécialistes du
québec gagnent plus qu en ontario sont
tient compte du coût de la ville
chaque médecin spécialiste gagne 400
mille dollars 80 m $ de trop
c'est un milliard par année vous vous
rouvrez l'entente et vous revenez sur la
parole donnée
on retrouve l'entente qui ont négocié
pions avec l'appui de la population
ça peut être bon 5 les médecins
spécialistes gagnent plus que ceux de
l'ontario puis que tous les autres corps
d'emploi incluant dans les hôpitaux
comme les infirmières gagnent beaucoup
moins que celle de l'ontario ya un
problème d'équité c'est difficile même
que des médecins spécialistes qu'ils
disent je me sens mal dallas l'hôpital
travaille et que des gens qui gagnent
moins que leurs collègues en ontario
alors que moi je gagne plus immigration
monsieur legault vos débuts cet éclair
test des valeurs après trois ans il est
un nouvel arrivant ne parle pas français
c'est beau by vous on ne peut pas
l'expulser rémois sont facilement si
vous savez je pourrais pas l'expulser
que vous en parlez encore d'expulsion
d'abord on ne peut pas changer notre
position depuis quatre ans de la même
position
ce qu'on dit un nouvel argument d'abord
on va les choisir davantage en fonction
de leurs qualifications en fonction des
besoins du marché du travail
le y vont avoir trois ans pour réussir
deux choses un test de français
un test de valeur ok ok à 20 d'avoir
leur citoyenneté avant d'avoir leur
citoyenneté donc pas parler vraiment
d'exposition la personne n'aura pas eu
citoyenne qui arrive si les choix vont
d'abord vous demandez qu'on demande
c'est un test de connaissances et
surtout un message à 106,3 est ce que
l'égalité en fin mai ce que bon la
démocratie est ce que personne va
répondre le nom à la laïcité
son garde le lieu des tests de valeur en
allemagne il ya 90 % des gens qui
parlent des tests de valeur en allemand
qui est réussite du premier coup
ceux qui réussissent pas ils réussissent
le 2e 3e test la langue la langue s'ils
réussissent pas après trois ans mais
sont intégrés ont eu des enfants au
québec fait quoi d'abord deux choses sur
les nouveaux arrivants selon le dernier
groupe qui est arrivé c'est quand même
grave
59% des nouveaux arrivants ne parle pas
français
c'est énorme ça a beaucoup augmenté donc
il ya un travail à faire pour mieux les
intégrer parce que oui les enfants vont
à l'école à cause de la loi 101 mais la
majorité des adultes ne suivent jamais
de cours de français ou les abandonnent
en cours de chemin mais je reviens quand
même fait quoi s'ils échouent prises
deux françaises à y arrive quoi que ce
monsieur
garicoix la même chose que touriste qui
vient visiter le québec puis après six
mois
il veut pas retourner chez lui puis pas
citoyen canadien il n'y a pas le droit
de rester si ça même chose c'est qu'on
dit la personne qui a pas réussi son
test de français
elle n'a pas sa citoyenneté canadienne
donc elle et quelques dîners donneriez
plus permis durant donnerait plus le
permis du québec exactement qui permet
d'avoir les citoyens si j'allais vous en
trouvez dans les lèvres comme un
touriste qui veut rester ici comme un
travailleur qui est un permis temporaire
qui est échue ça arrive déjà vous voyez
bien que c'est la partie la plus
controversée que vous laissez pas tomber
l'expulsion de 7 po nous on va s'assurer
qu'on va former ces gens là on va tout
faire qui apprennent le français ce post
mais leurs enfants vont apprendre le
français aux cellules si on disait c'est
pas sérieux sondhi est un test de
français obligatoires
mais si vous les choux il ya pas de
conséquences nous ce qu'on dit passage
par la normandie
il doit y avoir un test de français
réussit 6
non vous n'avez pas votre citoyenneté
canadienne et puis c'est le gouvernement
du québec on parle de l'immigration
économique l'a choisi ce 60% depuis très
bien si le fédéral impose un pipeline
par exemple mais ils ont fait la
colombie britannique
est-ce que vous redeviendrez souvent
indique t on des données si le programme
et quels facteurs france heures que le
fond d'un monsieur legault qui était
souverainiste ressurgir et quand on
parle de souveraineté
on s'en va vers un mur il n'y a pas dans
un avenir prévisible
une majorité de québécois qui appuieront
la souveraineté donc ne le choix ou on
accepte statu quo comme monsieur
couillard où on demande des pouvoirs
additionnels avec l'appui des québécois
ce que j'aime c'est quand on en aux
québécois êtes vous d'accord pour que le
gouvernement du québec ait plus de
pouvoir en matière d'immigration en
matière de langues en matière de culture
il ya une grande majorité des québécois
qui sont d'accord serait aussi vous dise
oui mais mais j'aime devant quoi mais
même justin trudeau
il s'est fait élire avec entre autres
des diptyques au québec
donc comment peut-il refuser la
différence c'est que dans le passé on
assite travailler sur le grand lac gelé
en même temps ci a pas de conséquences
et pas sérieux que mise sur l'innovation
c'est la même chose si on demande plus
de pouvoirs je peux le rapport allaire
est en fait ce qu'il a pu il n'y a pas
de réponse on fait quoi
il y aurait peut-être une conséquence
politique pour le parti fédéral qui
dirait non imaginez-vous qu'une majorité
de québécois qui disent on veut que le
gouvernement du québec et tous les
pouvoirs matière d'immigration puis
parti conservateur du parti libéral du
canada désire et non ils vont être mal
pris
le pouce faire élire au québec mais ça
ça vous inciterait part de venir
nombreux
très bien nous on et j'ai d'autres
priorités on est à une pause
publicitaire après des questions en
rafale
autour de 50 tramways gatineau ouest
troisième bien à québec
comment fait la priorité une
priorisation dents
[Musique]
je legault questions en rafale est ce
qu'il est possible de promettre aux
québécois un temps maximal d'attentes
aux urgences avant de voir un médecin si
oui combien tu as mais je pense que si
on parle de voir un médecin pas avoir
réglé son problème
90 minutes ça existe ailleurs comment y
aller il faut que les médecins de
famille en fasse beaucoup plus en
première ligne donc vous dites c'est ça
passait par une promesse qui reste vous
poursuivre pendant quatre heures salle
d'accord pour donner de l'argent public
dans un nouveau stade de baseball à
mourir si on est capable de montrer que
le montant que le gouvernement doit
donner est inférieur aux vraies
retombées au ministère des finances oui
est-ce que c'est construire le centre
vidéo 3 québec avec essentiellement de
l'argent public a été une erreur
non je pense que là aussi ça fait partie
de notre homme
et puis en particulier à québec montréal
pour retrouver notre vous y croyez
encore main dans la main avec monsieur
trudeau pour contrer la guerre
commerciale de monsieur tron
oui écoutez c'est très très très
important parce que ce sont des emplois
payants entre autres dans l'acier
l'aluminium
donc faut protéger ses acquis ces
emplois payants dans les régions
concession pour les halles gestion de
l'eau faites-vous vers des concessions
non ok très bien limités à deux mandats
le mandat de premier ministre du québec
pour ne se soit parité obligatoire dans
un conseil des ministres
oui c'est un engagement que gilles y
aurait autant de femmes que d'hommes
sinon plus dans mon conseil des
ministres 6 j'ai le privilège de le
faire au taureau de 50 tramways gatineau
ouest troisième lien à québec
comment vous faites raismes prolongement
au sud au nord comme en fait la priorité
une priorisation nature d'abord on parle
d'infrastructures d'après 100 milliards
sur les 10 prochaines années
c'est pas quelque chose seulement pour
le mandat on a besoin tranquillement
convertir aux transports en commun en
commun les citoyens mais ça pose et
qu'il faut les pénaliser en les faisant
souffrir en n'offrant pas ce qu'il faut
sur les routes entre autres le troisième
ligne
on en a besoin québec et lévis pour sur
la ligne rouge est trop chaud pour
montréal c'est paul c'est pas la
priorité des jeux de ealing qui vont
vers montréal
c'est plus prolongé leur m vers le nord
vers le sud donc vers les bancs de la
caisse via les aussi avec la caisse
toujours oui toujours avec la sp un
tramway jusque dans l'es6 de la fal et
plus loin est ce que le gouvernement du
québec un contrôle sur le prix de
l'essence qui fluctuent on a
l'impression qu'il ya de la collusion il
faut la seule chose qu'on peut faire que
le gouvernement fédéral se doit aussi de
collusion mais sincèrement ça fait
partie du privé ne pas beaucoup de
contrôles aller vous allez faire un test
de goût dans les sqc pour le canada j'en
ai jamais pris prochaine même aller
goûter aux produits du québec
est ce que le québec on veut changer la
loi
nous on pense que c'est à 21 ans qu'on
doit avoir la permission de consommer
est ce que le québec se porte mieux
aujourd'hui qu'il ya quatre ans oui on a
marché
le problème c'est que nos voisins ont
couru l'écart s'est agrandi en éducation
en santé puis en économie noter qu'à de
schiste a grandi ok mais vous
reconnaissez qu'on a fait du chemin neuf
avance et on a marché les autres ont
couru première priorité sous devenu
premier ministre
l'éducation l'éducation l'éducation on a
besoin d'avoir plus d'enfants qui
réussissent est ce que pour la
population du québec un avantage avant
un gouvernement minoritaire
moi je pense que il ya des plus et des
moins avec un gouvernement minoritaire
ou majoritaire
mais étant donné les bonnes propositions
de la caq ce serait mieux d'avoir un
gouvernement ma job à dia cac
que faites vous pour vous évader
françois legault pour vous prier fait
supporter j'aime beaucoup jouer au
tennis avec mes deux fils de 24 médecins
calais sont rendus qui me battent donc
c'est si je pense juste à sada seillier
temps en temps les battre c'est bon pour
l'orgueil huawei s'est calé sur la go
bonne campagne on se revoit lasserait
septembre lors du débat
bercy estime
[Musique]